le lavage des mains paraît que c'est
encore un grave problème dans les
établissements de santé au québec grave
parce qu'il ya des données compilées par
le ministère la santé qui ont obtenu
dans la presse
plus ce matin on apprend que les
employés de ces établissements se lave
les mains seulement 60% des fois où ils
le devraient sylvie benoît directrice
des soins infirmiers du sus de la
capitale nationale on parlait de ce
dossier là avec vous bonjour madame bono
oui bonjour mes pieds matin c'est chez
vous apparaissent verdier que voulait
confirmer les données 60 % des cas le
fier de la capitale nationale et être
humain qui est majoritairement composée
de soins de longue durée avec quelques
lits 62 lits de courte durée dans votre
petit alisation et ça n'inclut pas pour
la capitale nationale par le chi québec
et le cpq qui sont des hôpitaux de soins
aigus tout à fait les chiffres que vous
avez sont déjà tombés respectivement
bon alors expliquez-moi vous comme
directrice des soins est fabriqué ce qui
peut bien expliquer qu'on ne l'a pas les
mais 100% du temps d'abord il faut dire
que nous on est très préoccupée par ces
résultats là parce que l'hygiène des
mains est un geste qui gisent au bord de
l'eau pour les infirmiers c'est un geste
qui fascine qui est disponible également
on s'explique mal pourquoi le personnel
ne procède pas de viande et mais de
façon des nappes et ben je vais vous en
donner moi je les entends déjà dit
écoutez on court tellement d'un patient
à l'autre d'une zone à l'autre ouvre les
portes des places de l'icb ans on n'a
pas le temps en fait
l'hygiène des mains on peut procéder à
cette technique là avec nos usagers nous
patients c'est un geste qui est quand
même assez papier de je ne crois pas que
l'état soit le seul facteur
parce que c'est c'est quelque chose qui
peut se faire lors tout en marchant
un entrant dans la chambre alors nous on
parle pas que des lopettes pas le
facteur mais probablement qu'il ya une
attente de causes qui expliquent le
phénomène
parce que si on comprend que les
infections sont transmises bien des fois
on peut transmettre microbes virus comme
ça parlait mais par le contact par les
mêmes faits l'hygiène des mains est la
principale me veut pour réduire les
infections nosocomiales les infections
quand on tenait dans le newsfeed ayé
c'est vraiment mieux qui est qui a été
documentée qu'on est qu après est-ce
qu'on a des chiffres sur les médecins
est ce que les médecins cela plus ou
moins les mains ben je vous dirais que
oui on a leash nous salon le le titre de
professionnel effectivement j'étais là
qui mettrait ne font pas exception l'eau
les médecins de l'ap pour les mains que
les préposés aux bénéficiaires ou les
internes hier c'est le phénomène est
présent
malheureusement pour toutes les
catégories d'employés alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant vous allez vous
promener avec un sifflet ou avec avec
une règle pour taper sur les doigts
comme comment vous allez vous y prendre
en fait c'est sûr que des mains et nous
c'est sûr que au sud de la capitale
nationale on a vraiment mis des mesures
on a franchi un cran plus là parce que
les chiffres nous inquiète effectivement
on adopter une politique par exemple là
pour encadrer d'hygiène des mains qui
prévoit que chaque employé va signer un
engagement à procéder à l'hygiène des
mains lorsque c'est vrai que le faire y
mène de faire une forme de rappel à des
collègues par exemple qu'ils ne le
feraient pas également vous comprenez si
un engagement mais il y aussi des
mesures administratives peuvent
s'appuyer dans le cas où cet engagement
à l'eau n'est pas respectée donc ça
c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est ce qui est
nouveau la capitale nationale le dos aux
établissements qui on envoie t pas
également l'eau d'ailleurs nous on est
allé voir quelle était la stratégie qui
était adoptée dans les endroits où les
résultats semblaient d'ailleurs et c'est
ce qui nous a amené l'eau
mon maître en mieux dans ce que l'on va
continuer bien sûr d'en parler merci
beaucoup mana borno où on voit peut-être
les renvois